one moment as we begin our live stream
and
Sampras you have the hosting or the
presenter privilege
all right and the LinkedIn live stream
has begun
hello everyone I welcome each one of you
to the producively learn online
convocation ceremony
we will wait for a couple of minutes for
few of our other participants to join
and then we can get started
foreign
okay
hello everyone
a very good morning and evening to one
and all
today truly signifies the culmination of
your hard work in the Relentless pursuit
of knowledge
knowledge that will enable the person to
embrace opportunities and take on
challenges with a Clear Vision and
purpose
it gives me immense pleasure to welcome
you all to this online convocation
ceremony for the year 2022 hosted by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University
I am madhurima Senior program manager at
simply learn responsible for learner
success and today I am co-hosting this
event with mohini singer who is also a
program manager at sync leader
once again a big congratulations to
everyone for what you have achieved in
the last few months
I'm really excited for what the future
has in store for you
let's take a step back and remind
ourselves of the journey we have been
through
I believe the most difficult part of
this journey must have been to sit
through eight hours every weekend week
after week for six to ten months you
completed hundreds of hours of learning
through LBC classes OSL videos and doing
around 20 plus assessments
and projects taking up quizzes and then
finally implementing all your knowledge
in completing the Capstone project
and finally unlocking your program
certificate
it honestly requires a lot of commitment
and passion to achieve
achieve and I would like to take this
moment and applaud and appreciate each
one of you for your efforts many many
congratulations
last but not the least I would like to
thank your family and friends for their
continued support in making your success
students
moving on to the guests of honors for
today
our first speaker is Dr Bart Collins
professor of practice and director of
Graduate Studies in the College of
liberal arts at Purdue University
Dr Collins directs the prime lamb
schools graduate program which includes
the campus-based Masters and PHD
programs and the online master of
science in communication program
his current research interests include
health communication and science
communication
Dr Collins has been an honored
academician in the field of human
behavior where some of his recent
projects and research involve assessment
and evaluation of employee health and
wellness initiatives
his research also extends to the study
of anti-science attitudes
is also served as a faculty scholar in
the reconstrief center for healthcare
engineering Dr Collins we are delighted
to have you here for the cell we need
today a few words for our graduates
please
absolutely I hope you can hear me thank
you for including me in this ceremony
I've personally
valued the relationship Purdue has with
simply learn I've had the opportunity uh
to speak uh to uh classes uh over the
last year uh on on various topics
related to communication that that might
be uh useful to students in this program
and those have been a great learning
experiences for me we're just really
proud of the association we want to
recognize uh your commitment to
continued learning uh it says a lot
about you and we hope this work is has
made meaningful impact in your work uh
today uh but also uh long into the
future so
um we just really value the opportunity
to get to know you collab operate in the
delivery of this uh these programs that
you've been participating in and wish
you uh continued uh success boiler up
thank you for your words of Esther I
would not like to introduce Dr wil Lin
who is the chief marketing officer at
simply learn and our sponsor for today
when is a resin driven marketing
executive with extensive International
experience and proven track record in
managing 100 million dollars plus Global
Marketing budget
he has extensive experience in scaling
businesses and taking them to the next
level
he had worked in marketing and digital
leadership roles with organizations like
Microsoft Hewlett Packard Expedia and
Redfin among others
Dr Lin is a PhD in operations research
and industrial engineering and also
holds a masters in aerospace engineering
from the University of Texas at Austin
he currently resides with his wife and
two daughters in Seattle
he has been a huge influence in making
the Purdue programs at simply learn a
successful one will we welcome you to
today's convocation ceremony and would
like for you to share a few words for
our Learners please
thank you
um first to the fellow Learners I'd like
to extend my deep and Harvard congrats
to you on this achievement
you have a big group of us Purdue and
simply learn cheering along today as you
receive your certificate and we are so
honored to be part of the special day
I applaud you for your dedication it's
not easy to juggle among personal
commitments work and study all at once
so take a moment and Savor your reward
and celebrate with your loved ones
friends
and on social media and please do me a
favor if you will be celebrating your
achievement on social media please
remember to tag Purdue University and
simply learn
so I was asked to present the following
two slides to inform you more about your
fellow Learners the AFL is
self-explanatory so I'm just gonna let
you read through them
um
and I won't go into much details if
there's really one word to summarize it
all it's diversity
in this specific patch there are 944
Learners from 38 different countries
just imagine that 38 different countries
right so that speaks in terms of
diversity and and how Global
um this learning program has become
not only this group is Diversified but
highly educated and experienced so if we
can move on to the next slide please
so please make sure you continue to stay
in touch and network with your fellow
learners you may not have realized that
but now you actually belong to a elite
community of Learners who have completed
technically events and focused
intensified bootcamp
based on what I've come to know people
who successfully completed this type of
boot camps always demonstrate
characteristics of curiosity
hope passion courage Independence
self-confidence and perseverance you
have to be proud of yourself for
mastering these great qualities
as a member of this continuous Higher
Learning Community I'm hopeful that you
will become its advocator and
ambassadors
we Purdue University and simply that are
looking to work with you on your
continuous upskilling and promotion of
this new way of learning to your friends
and colleagues
finally
I hope that your new learn skill will
unlock even more doors to the success
you very well deserve congratulations
again thank you
thank you will for your wonderful words
now is the time to celebrate success
my colleague mohini and I will
collectively honor each and every one of
you who has completed the program
we will recognize all the Achievers in
each category and names will be called
out by program
we will also have a few of our graduates
share their experience with us as we
proceed
firstly we would like to apologize in
advance if we mispronounce your names
also in case if we have missed out
reading any of your names please do not
worry you can reach out to us and we
will surely accommodate you in one of
our upcoming convocation ceremonies
let's start with our first program
which is artificial intelligence and
machine learning cure we have
Ashwini bhagwan nithya Ashish alok nahid
akhil John Akshay Aman many
congratulations
congratulations
[Music]
Chewie
[Music]
Elvis
kudos to each one of you
srinivasa Sabri Nathan Abdul Neha logish
bastrian Benjamin pyron professor chawla
Papu Sagar raghupati Robert sakshi
Sharia Joseph
Faris ajish Ravi
Andrea many congratulations
prakash Richard Muhammad Sally
Sagar Varun Daniel
[Music]
congratulations once again
many many congratulations
Marina Paula Shreya raghav
swathi hardik Vivek Suma Anand shajanya
Vignesh vineet reshmi Sadat neetu and
John many many congratulations to each
one of you
before we move ahead with the next set
of felicitation I would like to call
upon Mr Ashwini Kumar sahai who had
volunteered to share his wonderful
Journey with us
can they please have Mr Ashwini move up
to the panelist
sorry to say this mother but Mr Sweeney
has not yet joined
thank you Rod uh we will move on so
mohini quality was in business analysis
we have
Martin
Joshua Kajol anusri sukanya jiben rupesh
congratulations everyone up next we have
hamrita anju hey month if
congratulations everyone
moving on to next we have Priya and
beige V Rajesh
shubham anmol arvind Tushar
congratulations everyone
up next we have shubham Amisha amarjeet
saurabh kriti abhimanyu ananya Elizabeth
Raja congratulations everyone
gaurav
Muhammad Imran Chanel Nayana Aman
satwika Sai Priya biblab
ayush
Kirin my
anupratan congratulations everyone up
next we have karthikey
bilali Austin
shravini vinay Sandhya Sangeeta
kudos to all of you up next we have
Maria Shivani
naraina
congratulations everyone
up next we have anyone twinkle
babatunde nikesh
Anna
Charles Neelam pallavi priyank Priya
Kush and Sharia congratulations everyone
next we have sridang Tanisha sakib
Muhammad Ahmed abhinav
Genevieve jyotika nagaraju BK Prashant
dude
congratulations everyone
next up we have Bella chitra
Vijay prabhat Don Cummings William dripi
DIA
dolma
Durban
s word
and Madina congratulations everyone next
up we have hariharan hariram harshali
Serena Zain Henry ravindra khalidi
Saleem indukri
AV is hard Ashwin Kumar jet lip van
Jagdish divyanshu Jerry and Vivek
congratulations everyone
next up we have
koteshwara James kalyana Kate Deva
madhumita
Priyanka Pavan Kumar kushal
Rashmi Indra Sai Mohammed
Malik Walid
manoharish and Michael congratulations
everyone
up next we have mayank Manish bukadam
hi there Alexandra Abhishek
Nandita Natalya Anil jawagal
advend pallavi pallavi Shetty badrinath
pavitra presidious prabhakaran prakriti
and Asha congratulations everyone
congratulations everyone
last but not least we have Shada Ryan
Sangeetha Yan yuk sadhu Sachin and David
congratulations everyone I would like to
call kriti Jain to share a few words
from our journey with from her journey
with us
now you are the panelist you can admit
yourself
okay
uh I hope you all can hear me
very good evening to all the members
there I just wanted to say that uh it
was a great experience learning with a
simply learn and as a fresher and
choosing a business analyst course was
really tough but simply learn really
made it easy for me and I had create a
professors who taught us really well and
all the courses that I have learned here
I hope to get a really good job and uh
Pro proper job assistance for the
further process and would really like to
thank you Purdue University and simply
learn for all the efforts that they have
made for each and every student here
so thank you so much
thank you
thank you kriti thank you for sharing
your story with us
moving on to the next program data
analytics we have Irfan gaurav suhani
Manisha Leonardo
Oliver Kevin Akash men congratulations
kudos to each one of you
many congratulations
congratulations
Fiona
the Silva Ashok powder John Carroll
Rohit Orlando many many congratulations
Chinese
glendalees Supriya divisha Amit sumitra
Irani Hazel shweta Aliya Ajay anugraha
Daniel himani Joe
oladipupo
Michael Catherine many many
congratulations
Naga
[Music]
Nita
akanksha alok Nayak Allah many many
congratulations
foreign
kudos to each one of you
Alexander Cena
prepared Michael shikha pratik ananya
Sandeep
shivaranjali Sarita bhuvanesh Suresh
snigdha Bala srija Virginia
Akshay sushma Praveen kudos to each one
of you
[Music]
many many congratulations to each one of
you
from this program I would first like to
call upon Mr ansh Krishna to share his
Learning Journey with us over to you
ansh
hello am I Audible
yes
okay hi everyone I am ansh I am a 15
year old and I live in Bangalore so
today I was told that I have to talk
about my experience learning on this
platform
so in a nutshell
um I'm actually a basketball player and
I'm a die-hard Laker fan so I actually
took up this course uh you know to I
want to make my own computer-based model
for the NBA because that's what you know
I I love watching the NBA and so I told
this to my dad and he said hey you
should take up a data analytics course
so I went on to Google searched for a
good analytics programs and came across
with this program on the simply on
website so
without thinking about it I got to like
ask my dad to buy me the course and I
started off I started off with a lot of
motivation sorry of a lot of enthusiasm
uh just how everyone starts a new thing
right but after the first live virtual
class I didn't think I'd make it through
I thought this was you know this is too
much for a 15 year old all these
Advanced stats and you know memorizing
the formula in Excel I mean it was my
first class so I thought I wouldn't make
it through but uh it took quite a bit of
persistence to get through and I
wouldn't have been able to finish this
without the help of the faculty of
Simply learn and all the amazing
teachers who explain you know really
complex things from the grassroot levels
so anyway that's my story and
congratulations everyone
thank you ansh for sharing your journey
with us
history have all Achievers in the
category of data Engineering in this
category we have Ganesh Vijay
pranabi and Carlos congratulations
everyone up next we have others Arun
Oscar Jennifer bhaskaran Collins Engen
Lakshmi Rajkumar Clayton Ivan Carlos
srijit Boulder hemant venkata
Davida ranjanan rice Robin Siddhartha
congratulations everyone up next we have
Krishna sushil lavanya Suraj Vivek
Violet and Vishal congratulations
everyone
we'd move on to our next program data
science the Achievers from this program
are chandan gaurav Avinash ankush Jain
murugan porik Hussain Ankit Kent sahana
many congratulations
[Music]
many many congratulations
congratulations
Aditi leonela harshil kaushal Thomas
Magdalena Anup Shashi anirudya sneha
apsara amruta demisio
Divya Hadi
ayushman nitin Leonardo daughters many
many congratulations
[Music]
many many congratulations
[Music]
foreign
congratulations
Rakesh Ramsey Rohan rupali sapna
Shashank Samira
Matthew biplov ho Kent shankanim vinod
[Music]
many many congratulations to each one of
you
Vishal sujit
ayush sushmita wasi abhishekila
rahil sonali John Jai murugan Jai
Lakshmi Islam Carson
Divya many many congratulations
foreign
congratulations once again to each one
of you from this program I would like to
welcome Mr Chandra shekhar to the
panelist and share his experience with
us
you are now the panelist you can unmute
yourself
can you hear us
I believe in the interest of time we
should move on and give children shaper
a chance later on to share his journey
with us we would really love to hear him
that would be great so for next category
we have all Achievers in digital
marketing in this category we have
Gayatri sanjana Abhishek archana samrat
Niti Sylvia vinayak Sulu Indra ashdosh
congratulations everyone
next up we have Sebastian ruchika Nikita
madhu chandana bhagyashree chitra and
samlas congratulations everyone
up next we have
archana nitish
congratulations everyone
next up we have Harsha Joel
Deepak
gaurav Shankar
congratulations everyone
next up we have
prabhakar Atul
um
Carlos chandan Singh pranali raghavendra
satay
snehal angita Patel
himanshu him shell and Neha
congratulations everyone a big
congratulations to you up next we have
Camille jadeep Mohammed Jessica kajal
kitika Kushi
lovely sanjivan Sanjeev Nat manasvi
susha Maryam Meenakshi Dr namrata Beth
and navneet Nair congratulations
everyone
next up we have Ahmad Nelson Nikita
nitin nitish
amol anant Ajit Patricia fan Eric
Emmanuel suhas critique
Kevin
congratulations everyone
next up we have
satender
congratulations everyone
next up we have Shri
nitishna and Tita Susan varsha Yusuf
vikas
congratulations everyone
last but not the least we have zeenel
Doshi who has completed the certificate
I would like to uh pass on the mic to
Gayatri to share a few words with us
regarding her journey
I agree on all the panelists you can
unmute yourself
uh hi everybody
first of all and I'm really elated that
I took this course is quite uh confused
whether took it or not
thank you
anywhere
you know
attending class
you know getting certain from really
I mean university university it's really
a great thing and I'm really happy I
took up and I completed like I that I
actually did it because of the previous
schedules that we face and people who
are working it's very hard for them to
pick up the course and stuff but uh it's
great that all of us could do that and
as well but uh
the content marketing side and uh see
where it goes in the near future looking
for jobs yeah I hope that this helps me
um my career as I thought and thank you
so much for uh simply learning for you
for the opportunity to share and
congratulations to all the people and
students of panelists and yeah thank you
for joining thank you thank you Gayatri
and all the very best for your future
[Music]
we would uh like to share his experience
with us he was facing some audio
challenges but I believe it's fine now
over to you Chandra shekar
you are now the panelist and you cannot
root yourself
good evening ma'am can you hear me
so I would like to give just two minutes
I will take off your time so first of
all I have been working on customer
projects which required deep attention
on Python and machine learning and which
I practice with the help of Simply learn
because there was like these kind of
videos which was made and they were so
properly made and properly done that it
gave confidence and the projects which
were there that gave the importance that
I can do it and I can score anywhere
anytime so in the current project I'm
doing well and in the near future I'm
definitely hoping to get into data
science thank you
thank you Sanju Shaker and wish you all
the very best for your future thank you
moving on to our next program which is
digital Supply Chain management our
Achievers for today are mayank Vari
rajal saurabh Sunil anoop Anthony
many many congratulations
[Music]
[Music]
many many congratulations
[Music]
many congratulations to each one of you
next up we have all the teachers in the
category of digital transformation in
this category we have
Ramesh Sunil mirabandhu Manish Abhijit
and silesh congratulations everyone
next up we have Niha murlidharan purnika
Rahul Steve sunit Suman Manoj
Kamal
congratulations everyone
next up we have satna jagat Anuradha
Ramesh Tanya and madhu congratulations
everyone
next up we have Sita Ram Priyanka
navneet sovik Prashant arvind Siddharth
Chef
Julie pankaj
sushiok and Sumit congratulations
everyone
next up we have Kanan Prashant Manish
Sunil subhadra Hamza Rahul Shaheen copys
garima and manjunath congratulations
everyone
next up we have mandar Amit rajini
sandesh Sean shashikand Lina Sachin
Susan sandish Manish mayank Mukesh Steve
Suresh and sujit congratulations
everyone
last but not least we have
anirudhane Puja project
Sunny George Dean
says
I stop for the data science category we
have pavitra Suresh and Muhammad adnani
hubby who completed the program in 82
days and hundred days respectively
congratulations pravitra and Muhammad
next up for the category of digital
marketing we have suhas diwakar zaili
completed the program in 94 days and
Shanda's a who completed the program in
106 days congratulations guys
next up for digital marketing category
we have suhas divakar who completed the
program in 94 days
I'm sorry I'm sorry so the category of
digital Supply Chain management we have
prabhakaran suruli who completed the
program in 94 days and cousin oswal who
completed the program in 115 days
congratulations both of you
last but not least we have pankaj Kumar
Sinha and Ramesh Babu botlab for digital
transformation who completed their
course in 86 and 88 days respectively
congratulations
I would like to congratulate each and
every one of you because your speed is
attributed to the time you allocated to
your work you prioritize this program
and it really showed
thank you and congratulations to each
and every one of you
in this ceremony we acknowledge your
hard work and a digital batch will be
provided for all the awards that are
backed by the learners congratulations
once again
mohini we have two Learners from the
winners sections who would like to share
their experience with us
so uh I think Mr pankaj Kumar Sinha if
he is available can be please move him
to the panelist
yeah you are now the panelist you can uh
you cannot mute yourself
could you hear us
not present uh however we have uh Mr
single uh Mr Cena sorry Mr Cena is
present and uh Mr Sana you are the
panelist now you can unmute yourself
I uh can you hear me yes yes
good evening everyone uh my name is
pankaj Sinha and uh
uh congratulations to all the members
who uh completed the courses on Purdue
and simply learn platform uh so my
personal experience with the digital
transformation course has been very
enriching and uh fulfilling one I mean
being from an I.T industry I had a
background of what digital
transformation is have worked on some of
the live projects as well for my
assignments but then this course gave me
an overlay of how things are progressing
and current scenarios in today's
industry I mean especially courses
materials like digital marketing and
digital leadership where the key
openness for me basically where I did
not have any visibility and under sight
on how things would work there uh
platform for the LMS platform is very
well designed and uh basically I mean it
slides you through
um completion of the course and
navigating very easily there's a I I was
able to complete the course uh well
before time uh because I took those
self-learning courses apart from the
live classes that used to happen uh and
and that uh that put me in Faster Pace I
think that that was the benefit that I
got from the LMS party overall I am
looking forward to apply the concepts
that I learned on the digital
transformation course into my real life
experience and I would also look up to
uh new opportunities that would come
across my way uh after completion of
this course so thank you thank thanks
thanks
everyone
and congratulations and best wishes to
everyone thank you
thank you thank you for sharing your
story with us
yeah are you available
you can unmute yourself
hello
yes we can hear you oh okay so now
um I would like to say that I know what
of course
and uh well structured when all kinds of
uh you know are big Market skills and uh
process and
um yeah it's really well structured so
that I could have a systematic View and
systematic um you know concept of the
skills uh that I had learned I have
learned from the course
um and also I would like to say the
projects um the case studies uh they are
um give them the structures as well
that's what each instruction like uh
what to do first question and third
um and that's really helpful for our you
know thought organization and um
organizing our thoughts and organizing
our uh you know workflow towards the end
uh so yeah I really enjoyed those
processes yeah thank you
thank you so much thank you for sharing
your journey with us
now I would like to to introduce to the
team behind the scenes the team that has
worked relentlessly to make sure that
you have the best learning experience
now this is for you to put a face on the
names you have heard him interacted with
in the pastor I would like to start with
a live class instructors they have been
the major pillars of your experience and
I would like to thank each one of them
on your behalf thank you to akshita Amit
amitendra Delhi good deep
and Prashant Naya moving on next we have
pradeep
Bernadette or not Mark meenal Varun cm
manjunath and nagendra congratulations
everyone
I would like to I would be honored to
have shubham Pandi in the attendance and
would like to invite him to say a few
words to our learners
and you can communicate yourself
first of all many congratulations to all
the Learners here
uh it really requires a lot of
commitment
especially those who have been walking
uh working for five days in a week and
then over the weekend eight hours of
continuous learning and then uh going
for assignments and all it is not easy
you are taking away time from your from
your family as well so it was a great
commitment uh very well done all the
very best and I also really enjoyed
interacting with you all it was a very
good diversity in the batches we had
people we had Learners who were freshers
and we also had people who had 30 years
of experience so it was a very enriching
interactions as well so I also enjoyed
interacting with you all thank you and
all the very best for your career ahead
okay thank you so much up next I have
prabh deep ketan who would like to share
a few words with our learners
I think now you are the panelist and you
can unmute yourself
yes yes we can
uh first congratulation to all graduates
who has shown their commitment for
lifelong learning
and really it is very tough to spend
like weekends
and that also like uh in the evening but
yes most of the people they spent this
time and they got the benefit of that
uh six last 25 years I am associated
with the industry and uh 10 uh almost
all the industries
but I realized one thing like uh in
Industry people they are able to
understand the basic process supply
chain process but they are not able to
understand the advanced level of supply
chain so I'm sure like all these
graduates they will lead from the front
where they will enter in the industry
and they will be a leader in the supply
chain field
so I am very uh grateful to Simply learn
and put it in the city for offering this
type of services to the all this uh
students
and by interaction with all the
participants was very good
uh they were very eager to learn a lot
of new things
and uh I also learned a lot of new
things from them
so thanks for that
thank you
thank you pradeep thank you for sharing
the words with the Learners up next I
would like to thank our masterclass
instructors for felicity.com we have one
more tree and one more instructor that
is wrong
the panelist you can unmute yourself
thank you hi hi thanks folks um a very
good morning good afternoon good evening
to all of you and my heartiest
congratulations to all of you I think
it's been an incredible journey for all
and I'm sure you're all very excited
that you've gotten uh this Milestone
here
and simply learn are both very esteemed
Institutes of learning and I'm sure um I
trust your association with them over
the past few weeks and months has been
an incredible journey of learning
for me personally I think just a couple
of things I want to call out that um I
think my colleague shubham did this as
well and I think it's important to be
remiss not to call it out again
the sheer diversity of all of you coming
from different roles and different
backgrounds I think added to an
incredible holistic learning experience
right I would personally I would look
forward to the sessions because the kind
of discussions the kind of questions
that came out
um was something that um was a great
experience for me as well and I hope
whatever experiences we shared with you
you'll be able to carry some of those
with you as you go forward uh happy
learnings going ahead and I hope um it
it helps you with your career with
whatever roadmaps your plan for yourself
so um once again congratulations to you
and your families for the sacrifices on
the weekends all the very best thank you
thank you for sharing your kind words
with us
next I would like to thank our Master
Class instructors for felicitating
classes on several interesting topics
every month
we will start with the master class
instructors for data science artificial
intelligence and data engineering I
would like to thank Ali L Gamble and
venkita inoklu for sharing their
experiences and their case studies with
us thank you Ali in venkita then we have
Master Class instructors for business
analysis digital transformation digital
marketing and digital Supply Chain
management we have Dr Bart Collins Dr
Zoo Eric Michael ADI and jinshu thank
you thank you so much instructors
up next I would like to move on to the
simply learned team that provided
endless support throughout your journey
these individuals were responsible for
moderating all sessions and the support
tickets you submitted many of you might
have interacted with them directly or
indirectly today we have case I Vishnu
cyprusad shreyas Abhishek maksud
vaishali jisme Irene and vikas moving on
next we have
I would like to thank you for your
constant support and the wisdom that you
shared in your work
next up we have the faculty and the
alignment team responsible for providing
the best trainers we have anvisha Poonam
Vijay
and Jonathan thank you team
moving on next I would like to thank the
product team this is the team that is
the brains for curating the program and
structuring it thank you Ankit
harshit Arnav came Chandra shivika
lovish and Shalini thank you team a huge
thanks to you
up next we have the content team which
is responsible for the live virtual
classes the labs and the self-learning
videos we see on our learnings
management system we have Kunal arushi
Dr anjana beshaki and Naveen thank you
team
up next we have
the leadership team who regulates the
direction of all programs and oversees
the learner's success team a big thanks
to Abhishek subhashani Amit coil Royston
my co-host madhurema Siddharth myself
mohini Sampras Rahul and akshata
I would like to take a moment to once
again thanks all the teams and applaud
them for their continued efforts thank
you team
up next I would like to thank all of you
who have actively reviewed us on social
media platforms we are incredibly happy
and excited to have received your
feedback and appreciation for the
program your feedback has made us work
harder fix a lot of things and move
forward to giving you and your successes
A Better Learning Journey here we have
our social media handles for you to
follow for more updates I hope you all
keep in touch with us
and now we have come to the end of our
online convocation ceremony we wish each
and every one of you the very best of
your future endeavors we believe that
being aspirational is the first step of
being successful you came here with an
aspiration and dream and we hope that
now you're confident that you are
holding the knowledge experience follow
through with what you have a dream of
we are honored and grateful that you
have pleased your trust in Korea
University in association with simply
learn thank you for your time and thank
you for making this event a successful
one
good night good day and good luck
everyone
thank you everybody
thank you everyone
thank you everyone for making it have a
good one goodbye
thank you everyone thank you so much and
congratulations once again thank you